exterior day sidewalk an aunt looms
monstrous in the frame crawling across
the rough landscape of cement in macro
it climbs onto an ice cream cone making
its way towards the Pinnacle of the cone
as it reaches the summit triumphant
music plays
but why why is this the opening of
season 5 episode 3 of Better Call Saul
if I take this random object and set it
carefully here with me in the frame you
won't really be able to help but pay
attention to it as long as it's there
because I've signaled that it's
important in some way you're going to be
inherently curious to find out what
happens to it later in this video
in the same episode as the ants there's
this scene where Kim and Jimmy I mean
Saul talk about each of their days it's
a well-written scene and the subtext
here is the two different directions
Jimmy and Kim's lives seem to be headed
I just realized I have all pro bono
clients tomorrow all day no Mesa Verde
as one celebrates being able to help
people and the other is hesitantly
making a lot of money by doing work for
the cartel financially speaking Saul
Goodman just had his best day yet
teaching but there's something else
going on in this scene Jimmy takes an
empty beer bottle from Kim and sets it
on the railing and the show really draws
our attention to this object and shows
Kim eyeing it up at the end of the scene
Kim grabs it off the railing why place
so much emphasis on this object why is
Kim eyeing it up is she worried it's
going to fall our answer comes later in
the episode when the pair meets back up
on the balcony since they last spoke
Jimmy has been drawn deeper into the web
of the cartel and Kim's day of pro bono
work was thwarted by an emergency with
her Mesa Verde case now Jimmy is
flirting with dropping the bottle and
what does Kim do
it's complicated to articulate exactly
the subtext that is packed into this
action in a sense it showcases how Kim's
frustrations with her work pushes her
towards more Reckless Behavior but it
also illustrates the weird push-pulled
nature of the dynamic of Kim and Jimmy's
relationship as they tempt each other
into trouble the nature of their
relationship on a macro scale and the
motivation behind their eventual scheme
to stick it to Howard plays out in a
miniature version of itself in these two
scenes the bottles and how Kim and Jimmy
interact with them allow us to see
what's happening with the characters
instead of just telling us how they feel
as Better Call Saul enters its Sixth and
final season I've been thinking a lot
about what makes it so special why I
love it so much and why it feels
distinct even in an era of an abundance
of great TV and have become increasingly
convinced that the show's Mastery of
visual storytelling plays a huge role in
that Showdown is such common advice in
filmmaking and screenwriting that's
basically a cliche at this point but
it's also much easier said than done and
so while the advice is extremely common
good examples of show don't tell or
visual storytelling aren't as common the
bottles are one example of how Better
Call Saul expertly uses props for visual
storytelling but it also uses the way it
structures scenes cinematography and the
performances themselves to show us
rather than tell us interesting things
about the characters without spoiling
anything from season six let's look at
each of these elements and examine what
Better Call Saul has to show us about
visual storytelling
Better Call Saul perhaps better than any
other show I've ever watched extensively
uses props as part of its visual
storytelling so much so that a prop is
often the visual centerpiece of an
episode as is the case with the ants in
the ice cream the ants on the ice cream
cone is a call back to the previous
episode saw Goodman
's for you where Jimmy's contented
success as Saul Goodman is rudely
interrupted when he's summoned by the
cartel
when the next episode opens this way and
we see the ants eating the ice cream it
reminds us of this moment which
establishes the main action for the
episode and it also sets the show up for
this payoff later in the episode where
Jimmy returns to the location after
doing business with the cartel and sees
the ants eating the ice cream the ice
cream isn't really important to the
show's plot it's not significant in
terms of the mechanics of what's
happening in the story but it also
allows us to see and feel what's
happening through a kind of
Representative symbolism this visual
story arc illustrates a kind of loss of
Jimmy's innocence as he begins working
for the cartel the childish image of the
ice cream cone is not only destroyed but
converted into an almost horrifying one
as if the innocence of it is decaying
when Saul sees the ants eating the
melted ice cream it looks almost
sickening and it kind of visually Clues
us into how he might be feeling inside
don't worry though those feelings won't
stop Saul's rise he's an expert at
pushing them down in my first video
about Better Call Saul four years ago I
talked about this trash can about how it
was used in the first episode to
illustrate Jimmy's frustration with hhm
we see him kick it but more importantly
before that we see that it's already
dented telling us that him taking out
his frustration on the can is a pattern
of behavior this trash can resurfaces in
later seasons and by attaching meaning
to this specific object the writer is a
Better Call Saul can then recall those
objects to remind us of story beats or
pieces of conflict without the need for
dialogue or Exposition the use of props
to show instead of tell is perhaps best
illustrated by Jimmy's world's best
lawyer mug the mug was a regular feature
in the early seasons and so the image of
it shot through with a bullet is an
evocative symbol of Jimmy slipping into
Saul his movement into more dangerous
territory and the death of a certain in
image that Jimmy has of himself but then
it also sets up this fantastic moment
where we get to see Kim realize Jimmy is
lying to her about what happened in the
desert
this is what makes Visual storytelling
so compelling it's that watching a
character realize something is almost
always more interesting than being told
they feel a certain way in the dialogue
but to do this kind of visual
storytelling you need multiple elements
working together creative writers who
are willing to use the props and the
physical world in an interesting way to
symbolize the conflict the characters
are experiencing and you also need
performances that can communicate what
is no longer in the dialogue when you
move it to a symbolic object wait Jimmy
Jimmy what
it's all good man
there's a short series of shots that are
together one of the most terrifying
chilling moments in Better Call Saul it
comes towards the end of season five
Jimmy and Kim are alone at home there's
a knock on the door
Jimmy's phone rings Kim goes to the door
Jimmy answers the phone we see a shot of
Mike driving like mad what I said right
now
can we see this shot of Kim reacting to
the person who's standing at the door we
don't yet know who's at the door
although we can probably make a guess
but the reason this moment is so intense
is because we get to see how the
characters are reacting to the situation
the show doesn't tell us how serious the
situation is it shows us how serious it
is in two ways first we see Mike driving
very fast uncharacteristically fast
actually for one of the show's most
methodical and calm characters second we
see Kim another stoic unshakable
character react with visible Terror to
who is at the door there's a lot of
setup that goes into the suspense and
tension of this particular scene but
it's the look on Kim's face at that
moment that really sells it for me and
sends chills down my spine Jimmy
in my earlier review of Better Call Saul
I talked about the show's richly
developed characters but what really
sticks out to me now is the way that
building a foundation for these
characters and allowing them to breathe
in the earlier seasons has started to
really pay off and how the show has been
cultivating what I think are some of the
most impressive performances on TV right
now Ray seahorn Michael Mando Patrick
Fabian Tony Dalton Bob Odenkirk along
with everyone else are absolutely
knocking it out of the park and the show
knows it one of the beautiful things
about TV is that you get to see what an
actor can do with a character in early
seasons and then write more for them in
later seasons based on what you know
their particular strengths are the
performances have always been great but
in the later seasons of the show it's
increasingly leaning on subtle moments
of performance and allowing them to do a
lot of the heavy lifting there are
entire story beats or plot developments
that hinge entirely around how well the
actors are selling pretty complicated
pieces of performance and for the
characters there are layers of Lies
hidden Innovations and performances
within performances which the audience
needs to be able to read visually in a
lot of scenes the drama of the scene
hinges on whether or not a character is
selling a lie to another character Jimmy
and Kim for example when they're doing a
scam nacho when he's undercover Mike
when he's doing some investigating the
drama for us the audience is not a
particular word or line or piece of plot
information within the scene but rather
watching the character's performance and
trying to see whether their Mark is
buying it going back to this climactic
moment between Lalo Jimmy and Kim part
of what makes it so dramatic and intense
is that what's dramatically important to
the scene is not really what the
characters are saying a lot of the scene
is even just Jimmy repeating the same
story walk me through it
what I told you already
yes but instead we're carefully studying
Kim and Jimmy's faces to see if they're
pulling off their Bluff and Lalo's
expression and reactions to see if he's
buying it I'm only stunned by the scenes
where we can feel the slight corniness
of Jimmy and Kim's performance within a
con that they're trying to pull off
oh hi and yet we can also completely buy
how it's working on their Mark these are
not simple performances for the cast to
pull off but nobody falters for even a
moment it might be strange to think of
performance as an element of visual
storytelling because sometimes I think
we over identify performance with the
way the actors say the lines but I think
in Better Call Saul the most important
elements of performance are often visual
The Secret of Better Call Saul I think
and a big part of what makes it feel so
different is that the major moments
aren't these massive twists or perfectly
delivered lines of dialogue it's smaller
than that but no less impactful it's the
flit of emotion or lack of it on a
character's face that reveals the show's
True Heart it's up to the writers and
the directors of the show to set up the
moments where we get to read a
significant story beat on a character's
face like this moment where we see Lalo
become suspicious before we're later
told that he is in dialogue lawyer said
his car broke down
but I don't think the writers would have
come to lean so heavily on these kinds
of moments if the cast had improved time
and time again that they could sell them
excuse me
may I help you oh I really hope so the
scam that opens season 4 episode 9 is a
beautiful example of visual storytelling
or dropped into the middle of the scheme
and we get to watch it unfold there's a
joy in piecing together what they're
doing and seeing what actually is going
on while what they're saying and
performing in dialogue disguises their
actual intentions so if you just listen
to the dialogue you get the LIE they're
exactly the same no one has to know but
you have to watch what's happening to
see what's really going on time and time
again the show just drops us into the
middle of one of these scams or some
other shenanigans that a character is up
to and lets us discover what's going on
as the character's process is in motion
why is my chewing gum ah yes I see now
why is Lalo climbing out of a manhole
why is he crawling back into it Better
Call Saul Revels in the details of a
character's process and then it shows
you why they're doing what they're doing
or when Kim quits weikart and Coakley
the show doesn't let us hear the most
obvious bit of that plot point the lines
I quit instead it frames the scene in a
much more interesting way we see Kim
have a realization and we see her taking
the steps of quitting and leaving we
slowly start to realize what she's doing
as the scene moves along
probably one of the things I love most
about the show is the sense of Discovery
you have watching it and a big part of
that sense of Discovery is that you
actually have to watch and pay attention
to the screen in order to see the
answers to your questions no exactly
does that work
doing things this way creates a real
tangible sense of mystery within the
episodes which is important for a show
where the broad overall trajectories of
so many of the characters are already
predetermined and known I think Better
Call Saul really shows it can be about
the journey with a character more than
the destination that even if you know
where a character is headed if you make
the process of the character getting
there interesting and dramatic will be
hooked
Better Call Saul has always had bold
striking cinematography that gives it a
distinct feel from any other show out
now but I want to move past how the
cinematography makes the show nice to
look at and focus on how the
cinematography is effectively used to
convey important elements of the story
visually for example this show really
uses wide shots like none other that I
know but these wide shots aren't just
cool they really flesh out the world
these characters exist in and Breaking
Bad you had a sense of Albuquerque
turkey and the show used both the city
and the desert in interesting ways a
Better Call Saul really finds a way of
integrating it all into what feels like
a single place they give you a sense of
the downtown landscape and position it
with the desert in the background and
they start using these night scenes out
on the edge of the desert where you can
see the light from the city shimmering
in the background it creates this
feeling of a place where two worlds are
colliding a shot like this illustrates
the separation between two characters in
the composition which also gives the
world such a real texture the locations
team does a great job in the show and
the wines really showcase what feels
like a vibrant tangible world that
surrounds the characters but this isn't
just nice aesthetically sometimes it's
actually important to understanding a
character's motivation like in this
scene where Kim has shown the room where
the backlog of cases in need of a public
defender are kept seeing the way the
room feels the neglect is a helpful part
of really understanding Kim's motivation
and why she's moved to do this kind of
work I've already mentioned how
composition can create the separation
between two characters but camera
movement can also highlight a
character's aloneness or a realization
they're having using a telephoto lens
can reveal heat Distortion rising from
the ground so we can actually see how
hot the air is Noir styled lighting can
make the characters feel trapped or
imprisoned or underwater and when you
build a show with mostly careful precise
locked down framing you can create a lot
of intensity in the moments where you do
break away from that and go handheld in
this scene which does that how its shot
Keeps Us mostly inside of Jimmy's
perspective emphasizing the chaotic
nature of his experience even when we
get a shot that isn't directly from his
POV it's close to the ground because
Jimmy is close to the ground and
sometimes you can increase the dramatic
tension of a scene by keeping an object
that symbolizes the dramatic tension in
the shot when nacho arrives at Lalo's
compound the doors of the Fortress are
visually emphasized we know nacho is
going to have to get to a door and when
he's caught off guard by Lalo being
awake and they sit down for a
conversation leaving the door in frame
increases the tension of the scene and
reminds us of what nacho is trying to do
this is a kind of chekhov's gun the
dramatic principle that states that if
there's a gun hanging over the door in
the First Act it should go off by the
third when heavy emphasis is placed on
something we read it as significant if
we don't yet know why it's significant
it will create mystery and will want to
know if it's a bomb we'll be holding our
breath waiting for it to go off creating
suspense in this scene we're waiting for
a literal bomb to go off when there's a
problem with the dynamite we wait in
suspense as Werner tries to find the
problem as he descends into the hole we
worry that the dynamite might explode
but then we see him have a panic attack
and the Show puts a more complex
dramatic bomb on the screen werner's
freakout is a problem that will
eventually explode and until it does
we're tensely waiting for it to happen
that's visual storytelling constructing
your story so that the audience sees
what is important and what you're trying
to convey rather than just having a
character tell it to them through
dialogue and it's what makes Better Call
Saul one of my favorite things on TV
right now this video is sponsored by
nordvpn a VPN is a virtual private
Network and there are two reasons I
think you might want one the first is
privacy when you're browsing the
internet you don't really have privacy
from whoever you're paying for your
internet so if you use a VPN it encrypts
all of your traffic and your ISP can't
see what you're doing you also can keep
your location private from the websites
you're visiting the other thing you can
do is use a VPN to make it look like
you're browsing the internet in a
location that you're not in with nordvpn
they have over 5 000 servers in over 59
countries your country might sensor
what's available to you on the internet
or maybe there are certain pieces of
media that you don't have access to
where you are and you can use a VPN to
get around Geo blocking and geofencing
in a lot of circumstances it's very
affordable too you can get 61 off and a
free month when you use my URL go to the
link in the description below I've
personally used nordvpn for years it's
very fast very easy to use there's also
a 30-day money-back guarantee so it's
totally risk-free to give it a try grab
your huge discount by going to
nordvpn.com
tflight or click the link in the
description or on the screen thanks
again to nordvpn for sponsoring this
video
foreign
[Music]